we get started we're just gonna jack
that up to about that big
she'll be big enough everyone
okay so emmalin no I didn't forget to
write slides I was too lazy to write
slides so we're gonna do something
totally different we're gonna write a
presentation together as a Python module
why not
it's easier than writing slides and
maybe we can have some fun the title of
this talk is the title of this talk is
more generators and I think one of the
very first talks I ever gave at PI data
at a PI data event was about generators
in fact the very first PI data
Londyn that I ever attended in 2013 boy
that's going back a long way I gave a I
didn't actually I didn't I gave a
keynote because the other guy cancelled
and so I had the whole audience to
myself and so let's see let's see what
we can do now five years on with
generators generators have been around
in Python for 15 years or so interesting
question that I keep coming to is how
come you see people talk about them at
conferences and everyone thinks they're
such a cool feature but nobody really
uses them like you don't see any big
libraries use them as a core metaphor or
core API other than some of the async
stuff how come it doesn't show up that
much in the field of data science now
one huge disclaimer despite having
spoken for now my fifth year in a row at
a PI data London and having spoken at 25
pi data's in the world I don't really
know a whole lot about that assigns or
machine learning I do mostly scientific
computing I'm more of a programmer that
I have anything else so please if you
want know what a lot about programming
just just leave the room I won't be too
upset okay so let's get started my name
is James Powell you know this is the
Python community so I really should make
sure to include my Twitter handle or I
should put my email here so I'm James at
don't use this code comm and my Twitter
handle is also
don't use this [ __ ] okay so we'll make
sure that we print those out so we can
get started probably the most important
things now as you can see at the top of
my file here I have a couple of simple
vim macros just to make my life easier
so as we go through this I'll be
pressing one of those key combos and
you'll see some output at the bottom of
the screen and so let's see if we can
use that to kind of follow along now one
unfortunate thing here is because these
aren't slides I can't do the
self-promotional thing of getting all of
you to follow me on Twitter by having
like a big Twitter thing at the bottom
of the screen but because this is Python
you know we can just override print to
always print my Twitter handle every
time I print something out so let's just
do that really quickly and we'll see
that if this gets annoying or not will
say from built-ins import print as
underscore prints so don't lose the
original print will print what we were
originally going to print and then we'll
print out oops
we'll print out follow me on Twitter at
and then my Twitter handle yeah this is
gonna be the hole it's gonna be able to
45 minutes folks get ready get ready for
this and let's just put this all the way
on the side of the screen there we go
and let's give this a try with this
module and see if it works well oh and
by the way we need to make these
from built-in to import print ads this
is Python three that's one small thing
we have to make sure that we're using
Python 3 here so we'll just there we go
because unfortunately sometimes other we
got follow me on Twitter although that's
kind of annoying so what we'll do is
we'll just play with this a little bit
this is look this is harder than it
looks by the way this is much harder
than it looks folks I'm not faking it
this is for real if first and first pop
else cuz we want this to be really
classy we'll only put the Twitter handle
we'll only put the full follow me on
Twitter for the first time it prints out
there we go isn't that fantastic so
hopefully we won't do this for the whole
talk cuz that will be really tedious but
that's kind of what you're in store for
if you want to leave now that's okay
let's give you a quick overview what
we're going to talk about in this
session
it took us five minutes to even print
out the title so let's see how fast we
can go so the first part we're going to
talk about a little bit of review the
second part and so this part in the
second part we are going to talk about
what generators actually are in the
third part we're going to talk about why
they are not what you think they are
and the last part we're gonna have some
fun okay now let's get started with what
generators really are
so we'll just create a new file called
review dot py we'll grab these from the
top and you want to grab the print and
really actually have us print out my
Twitter handle every slide or every
print
okay good neither did I that's just
going really to you okay so let's figure
out what a generator you really do want
me to do that every time okay
otherwise otherwise you might think I'm
faking this whole thing okay so there we
go so there's our custom print function
okay I'm gonna start off with a very
simple question and since this is so
tedious to see on the screen we'll just
zip those let's start off with a very
simple question for you
my question for you is what's the
difference between these two yeah we can
try that you can also sit closer to the
front the colors will rise like hey look
at that
thank you very much for your feedback
okay what's the difference between these
two got function okay come on folks this
is like the very beginning what's the
difference in these two okay now if I
make this a little bit simpler and I ask
you what's the difference between these
two from the perspective of somebody
just using them who can't see the source
code is there any difference between
these two from the perspective of just
using these two they do the same thing
right
they're basically formal differences and
what you could say as well somebody were
clever there might be some help text on
this and you wouldn't see that help text
on the add two because it's an anonymous
function right but you see the help text
on the ad and the name wouldn't be right
but then I'd say you know what this is
Python we can just monkey patch this
thing right and this name equals add two
and then it's really it really becomes
difficult for us to distinguish between
these two and in fact it turns out that
these are just two ways to write
essentially the same thing except there
are certain syntactical restrictions to
the lambda that we don't have in a
normal function we can't have statements
it's just expressions let me throw in
another example and I want to tell me
what the difference between this is and
we'll call this a door
we'll put a pass here so we use this in
a second okay
how about this one what's the difference
between this structure and the previous
structures do you see any difference
still adds numbers it's just a different
formulation and you might say well we
still have the problem with the name and
the help text but trust me we can patch
that out now what an interesting thing
here is you might say well there is a
difference because if I have this adder
I can take this code and I can move it
somewhere I can't move the other code I
can do things with it but I can't do it
the other one right I can do something
like this and I can initialize this to
zero and when I actually run it I can
give it some kind of weird behavior
where it remembers some state because
this is an object and objects are about
State and so now the adding behind the
scenes that transparently adds something
in there but I'll tell you what are you
talking about that's nonsense I knew the
same thing with my original add up here
right and I really didn't do much to
change this and you might say ah but
James there's something more let's do
they've gotta make this global and you
could say you can actually even do more
you could say you know I don't really
like using Global's even though that's
the same and you know having this global
state it's not encapsulated and I'll say
oh it's not encapsulated is it well can
I do this
I just add it's a function right
functions in Python can have they have a
little dick so you can see behavior is
the same but you might say ah but if you
are being really clever you could make
two versions of this and they operate
separately because it's a class classes
can create instances right and because
classes can create instances we can have
two of these and they both have
independent state right and I might say
yeah but but why can't I just do this
and then I don't even need this this
crazy thing here I just use non-local
and then we finally get tired of this
exercise and what we realize is that
what we have discovered here is a
fundamental principle of computer
science namely and I'll finish the
example before I tell you what the
principle is boy I must be
very concentrated to be able to talk and
code at the same time huh who's
impressed I hope some of you impressed
this is really really hard this is
really hard okay so there we're there
and we're done so we can see exact same
thing and in one case we have a closure
and a function returning the [ __ ] the
other case we have an object and we've
now discovered first hand by trying to
tease apart some differences a
fundamental proper interval in computer
science which is objects and closures
are identical there's a clear
equivalence between them let's park that
for a second and let's talk about
something slightly different here's what
we're going to talk about that slightly
different let's let's take let's pretend
that we have a function that computes
something and because I because this is
hard enough as it is
I'll just give you a dumb compute
function that doesn't do anything that
interesting but it takes a tenth of a
second to run right so it returns a
random number between 1 and 10
and it takes a tenth of a second run see
you'd even feel that you never feel that
tenth of a second there now I can have a
function just a regular old function
that maybe he does a couple of
computations in a row
so maybe it calls this function 10 times
right and I can print out what this
function does
and we can see this in actually should
take about a second and you can see it
takes about a second now I can look at
this and I can say that's very
interesting it takes a full second it
computes everything upfront and I can
use what I learned up before to see if I
could just take this code here and put
it into my class formulation all right
there we go
and again if I do this you can see this
oh we have to of course we'll put a mark
up here there we go and you can see they
both do the same thing now one thing
that I can notice is that typically when
I actually want to use this I'm just
gonna iterate through the values right I
will put a mark up here just so we can
you know the last time I did one of
these presentations it went on YouTube I
got 300,000 views and then some people
in the comments were like wow he's
really good at using them and then some
guys like he's such a noob his vim skin
a sock he doesn't even use VIP for
visual in paragraph but I'm like okay
you gotta step up my game so I'll try to
step up my game here but you can see you
know this is the example we really
happened that YouTube comments are harsh
they're always very harsh but you can
see we have the same equivalents now
something interesting we can see it's
because we're iterating over this one
thing that we might know is that in
Python whatever we have a structure that
looks like the following
we know that behind the scenes Python
turns it into something that looks like
the following
and then there's a cat right here and
then you try and get the next value out
of the iterator the excise tense right
and an iterator for that and you accept
a stop iteration and break so we know
there's an equivalence here and we know
that if we if we implement it or and
next we can do something kind of
interesting so I'll show you what we can
do we can create our own object that's
it Oracle will say that it's it's own
iterator and in the next we'll just
return the next value well what we'll do
is in the iterator we'll just keep track
of the size of the computation we want
to do which is 10 and the next we'll
just say if not self dot size raise stop
iteration otherwise decrement self dot
size and just return this right and now
if we look at this and we no longer need
DS here if we look at this we have and
we have to go back up to our mark to run
everything we can see does the same
thing so what we've discovered here is
that there's another concordance here
that we can swap out calling something
for iterating over something but if I
were to tell you and we can see that
this result is actually a lot better
because one thing that you notice from
the two variants if I give you these two
variants side by side there's one thing
that I want you to notice and this is
one of the keys that people first learn
when they learn about generators and see
if you can notice it okay
did you notice something let me put a
break let me put a little visual break
between the two instances of these two
functions I want you to tell me really
quickly anybody sees a difference
between these two formulations because
all I've done right now is you kind of
played around with sticking some code in
a different place anyone see something
really visually different there
one's immediate and the other one is
streaming what we discovered here is
we've discovered some laziness now
something kind of interesting occurs
when we think about generators and
Python because there is some distinct
advantages to the second form namely one
notice there's no storage we're just
doing one computation returning the
value here their storage notice number
two we're getting the values only as we
need them so if we only looked at one
value the top version takes all of one
second and the bottom version only takes
a tenth of a second see that first one
took the entire time it was eager to the
whole computation and gave us the whole
result we threw away 90% of it the
second one only gave us a results as we
wanted so we can say oh that's really
interesting that's a lot more efficient
for both a memory and a time perspective
we're customizing what we what resources
we use in terms of computational time
and memory - exactly what the user wants
and the whole nice thing about
generators is generators are this idea
that you can write a formulation the
above both out all of this tedium so we
can just write this here grab our code
from here and we can see this generator
formulation here and this class
formulation here are just as equivalent
as this function formulation here in a
class and this raw formulation here so
we can see is that generators are a way
for us to very conveniently formally
describe a structure that performs a
computation on demand where internally
the structure itself looks very similar
to something that has a knitter and a
next employee okay so that's a review I
hope that was well within what all of
you know because that's just the start
of where we're gonna be let's take a
look at has anyone lost okay let's let's
take a look at next what large errors
so one of the things that we saw from
that example and while I grab the top of
this file here and my print statement
which we didn't use because I wasn't
highlighting each time but we'll use it
by the end and we'll just hide some of
this stuff because it's little garbage
on the screen like that this what we saw
is that we saw immediately some laziness
versus eagerness one of them runs to
completion one of them does the entire
computation the other one eagerly gives
you the computation as you go and what
we saw and what we might also know is
some kind of pipelining mechanism so one
of the things that we see from that
generator is the generator only gives
you values as you asked for them so if
we take our compute let's just copy our
compute over if we have actually know
how about this from review import
compute oh look at this this really is
now a Python package not just a module
and we I'm doing this off top of my head
come on gotta give me something oh let
me just do this and let's call this
okay there we go because the other
module has that at the top now
everything's gonna have this isn't that
great let's do this pretty cold that's
that's gonna be so annoying let's go be
so annoying okay so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna do a little bit of we're
gonna be nice to you cuz that's just
gonna annoy you
I'll just move this out here to top
okay there we go
so what we can see is we have now an
infinite sequence right so if I say for
X in F print X I now have an infant
sequence which would be very difficult
to monitor eagerly because you can't
store an infinite sequence anywhere and
what we know from this is we can do all
sorts of cute little pipelining things
just like at the shell things which
approximate the kind of data pipelining
that we often do on fancy platforms like
Hadoop and spark and whatnot and we know
that Python gives us the hitter tools
module inator tools module gets a lot of
helpers so we can do things like take a
generator at Tia to make copies we can
enumerate that to get you know the index
of it and then we can do something like
slice each of these so we can offset
each of these by in amounts and then
what we can do is we can zip them
together to put the star here make sure
we have enough closing parentheses we
could zip these together and this is a
very useful tool called n wise that
gives us pairwise views of some
structure all right so I'll show this to
in action you can see just using what's
in Python we can get like pairwise views
we need a BBC CD and we can even take
this further and we can do fun stuff
like getting windowed averages which is
just the sum of these values divided by
the length of these values for some
values in a windowed size of whatever we
want and so now we can take all of this
fanciness and we can do windowed
averages of f of some sighs let's do
windowed averages of size 3 and now we
have a lot of little helpers in a very
terse almost functional form you can see
it's processing an infinite sequence of
numbers and getting like the 3 windowed
averages right we need two moving
averages and that's really cool but
there's more there's one other thing
that we might we might have noticed and
I want to ask you is anyone ever seen an
API that looked kind of like this let's
do this three times
there was some function that you had to
run first there was some function that
you had to run second and there was some
function you had to run last and you had
to run them in those orders otherwise it
would be you know total anarchy cats and
burying dogs crossing the streams
absolutely absolute chaos you had some
API that's really order dependent and
it's so easy to screw up because there's
nothing enforcing that order well one
thing that we also know about generators
is that they are a sequencing mechanism
so we can't take all the code that we
wrote here you know the average
programmer writes 100 lines of code a
day and we're already at 200 so you're
really getting your money's worth folks
we can do this right and fi will be an
instance of this generator and we can do
this and you can see we get sequencing
except we can't screw it up and we might
even know that in Python 3 6 and later
we have this async/await structure so we
can even do stuff like this you know
create tasks that yield and print some
message out and we can write our own
scheduler and
right and we can just you know do
something like scheduler or tasks
hello task goodbye and we can see it and
we can see that the sequencing is
actually very important it's key to why
we have generators as the async
mechanism in Python for for single
processes asynchronous you can see that
what you have from the scheduling is the
yield is actually doing literally what
it says yielding control back to the
scheduler and the scheduler is figuring
out how to enter loose so this is why
generators work this way now let's talk
about something else let's talk about
why generators don't appear in data in
in pi data talks why I'm gonna has given
this and it's not just because I'm done
that's all I know
that is what answer this is really all I
know I wish I could give a talk on
machine learning I'm sure it would be
interesting maybe as interesting as the
average machine learning talk is which
is I will I will that we're really going
off the rails here aren't we I will say
that one thing that we don't see a PI
data conference is we don't see in the
world is you know out there there's
probably like a million biologists whose
state-of-the-art tool that using its
pearl and so a tool like generators is a
step Python itself is a step beyond what
they're doing and Python with generators
they're doing a lot of text processing
on like DNA sequences and looking for
substring matches and maybe this is an
appropriate technique for them but we
don't see this in the world of
scientific computing or numerical
analysis and I'll give you an idea why
that is one problem is that
fundamentally even though there's a very
nice lazy mechanism Python is pretty
pretty junk at doing anything numeric
computing related so I'll show you a
very simple example let's just do let's
just time to operations
well time using this generator and this
window to average mechanism against and
I'll get I'll get this code from up here
because I don't really want to cut
they want to import that well time this
against just doing an operation on like
a numpy and da-rae random import random
and we'll just create a random number
and D array with the values from zero to
ten of size and million okay and what
we'll do is we'll just do very similar
to have that n wise up there works we'll
just do something like this to get the
window to views and we'll just divide by
two and we'll see how long this takes
make sure that we nothing this time it
and we only run this five times because
it's not gonna be that fast okay you can
see it took like point one seconds here
and we'll try the same thing with our
generator approach and we'll see what
happens and it's not gonna be it's not
gonna be very good it's just that Python
integers and Python lists or even Python
generators are just not a very good tool
for any sort of numerical computation
you can see why as a tool these don't
really show up when you're doing large
unistream multiplications or you know
vector operations
we'll just take take this from here and
take that from there we don't need you
don't need this stewey and we'll just
say from random import ran range X s
equals R and rating from zero to ten for
this range this is like an interview
this is like the heart this is the
hardest interview that means the least
I've ever done and will do this list
windowed I hope if I ever interview at
any of your companies you ask me exactly
the questions that we're covering in
this presentation but we'll see how fast
this is and we probably need to make
sure we type this right they ever seen
anyone live code this much code and get
it right I've never I've never done this
before this is really special you can
see the speed of these two things boy
this is slow and windowed average let's
try that one more time I see it's really
really really slow even the construction
of the in C it's the two seconds versus
0.09 cents for a million integers right
so you can see even at very large scales
if I make this a billion yeah we have we
have easy memory use but if you want to
do anything numeric involving large
streams just use an umpire in the array
its cache coherent it's packed into
memory it's just going to be faster this
generator approach and using lists and
Python integers for anything that's
mathematical in nature it doesn't work
so I think this is one of the reasons
why we don't see generators being used
as part of data science libraries in
this kind of numeira
stream processing sense because for if
you're doing text processing you're a
biologist and you're comp the
computational part of your computational
biology isn't really that computational
yeah it's a great tool if you're doing
serious machine learning or models or
deep learning it's not actually a very
valuable tool because it's hindered by
the poor mathematical support in Python
itself Python is an orchestration
language a glue language and a mechanism
like generators is not going to give you
the ability to do that much but let's
look at the last part of our
presentation we have 15 minutes let's
have some fun because if we really think
about it when we go back to what we
learn about generators in the second
section and we think about this
sequencing what we can see is that
generators are a mechanism that can fit
into orchestration they can allow us to
do to give us structure to a program
that the program might not already have
they're not necessarily a computational
mechanism they're not about you know
doing very quick vector operations
because numpy can do that way better and
if it's out of memory you have other
tools that can do out of memory
you know julia can do out of memory
operations as part of the core language
what you might think though is
generators might be a tool for structure
in a program and what's a common
non-mathematical structuring for a
program we're about a graph right we've
seen this these used to be all the rage
like a year or two ago I don't know why
they're not that popular anymore but the
idea that you could take some equation
and do it as a graph and if each of the
nodes are very hard to compute you can
minimalistic leary compute the nodes to
get some results so think about some
operation where your will do this very
simply we'll do something like this do I
really have ten minutes because I don't
need ten I only need 10 minutes to
finish this ok what we're going to do is
we're going to build in the next 10
minutes a graph computation framework at
about 70 lines of Python using
generators so what we might have is you
might have some term and the term is
just a generator that yields its own
value and
yep and new value and this is gonna be
really really sloppy so we can always
improve this slightly we'll do something
like this okay so this is just a
generator that can take new values just
a little computational unit we're going
to fit it into a larger structure and
maybe it will do simple simple addition
of terms okay and this again will be
something where we set the value to none
and what we'll do is we'll do like a
while true and we'll say value equals
sum of next e-40 in terms okay and you
can see we need to add term one term to
term three and by virtue of these being
you know live computational units we can
say for X in Q critics or actually we'll
do it like this while true print next
thank you okay now
every time we do this we do a loop but
let's do and we have to yield the value
you can see we just sealed this value
and if we want to we can make this a
little bit a little bit easier to read
so we'll just say from itertools import
count for step in count if step equals
two we'll actually inject a value into
one of these so you don't descend and
we'll send the value 10 in instead of
one and then if step equals five we'll
break out of this okay so here you can
see that's even reactive right we can
send something in at recompute but it's
not lazy yet right and there's a couple
of kind of irritating things that we
have to do with this you'll see the
first few values are not quite correct
now it's not lazy and we want to make it
lazy now one problem is unlike Python
functions you know a Python function one
thing you might have noticed is you can
define a Python function like this and
you can throw attributes on it you can't
do that with the Python generator
instance you can't throw attributes on
it so here we'll need to continue to use
a generator formulation but we'll wrap
it in a larger object so what we'll do
is we'll create just a very simple
decorator and we'll call it wrapped and
we'll have a class here called wrapped
and we'll just wrap our generator so we
have a place a storage place to put
something like this
and we'll pop it this is one thing
you'll find with these co-routines you
have to pump them and we don't have time
to talk about this we'll do something
kind of interesting we'll send our self
into this so we can do something like
this
at the top of each of these generators
we can actually keep track of the state
of it itself okay
and the rest of this is fairly
boilerplate and we won't implement the
entire protocol okay and we do something
like that now as we do this we can do
the follow up we can say actually know
where did that so what we can do is the
follow here when we have the terms that
we're adding we might say for each term
we can say t dot subscribers plus equals
1 and we can keep track of how many
people are subscribing to these values
so we know if we're dirty or or not and
we know how many people are waiting to
see values from us then what we can do
and this it's really inconvenient
and we'll just clip this to zero we can
always every time we yield a value we
can just decrement by one so we we're no
longer we're no longer a dirty value and
then what we can do is we'll use our
same trick from before we'll put a
little sleep in there just so that we
can see the dirtiness like take effect
here in the term what we can do is we
can say whenever we compute the term we
can mark ourself as dirty and we can
sleep for some period of time and so
what we'll see is as long as we're not
dirty
it'll just instantly recompute if we're
dirty we this represents a little small
but very large chunk of a computation
like a deep learning model that's
connected in a graph up to something
else right some learning model that
takes a few seconds to run but only is
run and the graph only recomputes it on
demand as we go up here in the ad it's
not that hard what we have to do we just
have to say if any of our terms are
dirty we just mark ourself as dirty
and we recompute our value so we'll just
freakin will only recompute our value
here but we will compute it once up here
okay so let's see if this thing works
there's gonna be real pain the debug if
it doesn't and then we'll just set
seconds equals to zero so that most of
these are instantaneous and then what
we'll do is we'll actually the one that
we tweaked we'll see and then functions
not iterable oh thank you and I have to
wow you're really paying attention one
more thing and we yield our value here
and
in terms routine terms we have to we
have to decrement this up here
we're also decrement it for dirty here
and let's see if this thing works
there's one last thing that we're
missing so I'm not I'm not stupid
I did actually prep a little bit at the
set of time we'll just grab from my
preparation yeah so we'll just grab my
prep diversion here oh we actually have
to use our wrapped class as well let's
see if we can continue let's see if we
can continue with this without screwing
this up too much but if not we'll switch
over to the canonical version but I did
I mean I didn't actually practice this
thing I'm not doing this all stop my
head okay
so we'll switch over to the canonical
version real quick and we'll just grab
we'll just remove this code here set
paste grab the code from my canonical
version which I promise you I haven't
been cheating the whole time on
and move on and what we can see through
this approach is that
we can pace this okay yeah I know where
that I do know where we're going with
this we'll just grab this code here and
I'll show you this in practice and this
version was the final version that I
wrote in preparing this and I'll show
you the final version because I don't
want you to have to suffer too much of
reading through me live code this it's
gonna be real difficult to debug there
we go
but this is the final version in about
eighty two lines of slightly harder to
write than live coded on stage what we
can see is we can see down here this
generator it'll pause for 10 seconds
when one of the values is updated and
the extra 20 lines of code mean that it
also will I mean it's a graph
computation framework so it'll also
graph the thing so you can see this is
our ad this one's a much harder
computation there's an Ag think it's
another ad we'll close it close it and
you can even see the terms go dirty
though that's like the 9 you can see
that's the one second wait for it to do
the recomputation and it's happening at
each levels and then it should up you
can see that one went dirty and then you
can see each of the results are now
faster again because it's not very
computed and you can see that dirtiness
propagate through the network about a
hundred lines of code using a generator
as your fundamental organizing structure
and I'll show you all I added here was
not that much the only thing I added
here was a little bit of an additional
mechanism to use Network X to draw the
thing and you know I guess it's a little
bit easier to do five minutes before you
get on stage though when you're on stage
but for the most part you can see this
code is essentially the same it's just a
generator that yields its values that
waits for it to be signaled as dirty and
then results and you can see this
generator is actually an interesting
structuring mechanism for larger code by
itself it's not an interesting
computational mechanism but what tricks
like this you can form interesting
structural things because each generator
by virtue of being a fixed they a an
object that represents a computation it
can also do neat things like if I had
three generators in a sea
Quinn's I could have themself elide
themselves and infuse into another one
this is the second example I wanted to
do if I happen to be running faster than
I thought I would which is to show you
how you can have a pipeline of three
generators that automatically rearrange
themselves or fuse themselves with
another twenty lines of code and it's
actually not that difficult and you can
see the API here maybe it's a little bit
of a little hinky but it gives rise to
thinking about form formal structures in
their code and I say even though this
API is somewhat hinky a comparable graph
formulation framework that does just
these two pieces there's gonna be at
least two hundred three hundred four
hundred eyes of code with generators and
a little bit of knowledge of how they
fit into how Python objects work and the
structuring behind them I mean I have 95
lines of code here for a graph
computation framework not too bad and I
almost got it right on the first try
live coding it so I hope you enjoyed
that that's more about generators thank
you so much
[Music]
you
[Applause]